actor Mark Wahlberg in Carson City today
pitching lawmakers on major tax
incentives to bring the film industry
here to Las Vegas as for where this
might be happening well there are two
planned locations already now these are
some of the renderings of the proposed
Studio site in Summerlin South the deal
also would enhance the film department
at UNLV and create a new Las Vegas media
campus also in the southwest part of the
valley both of which Wahlberg says would
bring well-paying jobs to the valley I
said we want to create as much
opportunity for everybody as possible
there's so many jobs that can be created
just in the one Studio alone you're
talking about thousands of thousands of
jobs very high paying jobs so many
amazing storytellers out there and so
many amazing stories to be told
now so far Sony has reached an agreement
with the Howard Hughes Corporation and
out of today's meeting in fact Disney
may be next in line for a studio
presence but lawmakers would have to
move quickly it has to make it through
several votes by Monday night